evaluate this guy here you remember this
scissor is that an NCR notation which we
also write like this that would be the
equivalent okay so same deal right
evaluate that from one up to end one all
the way up to end okay
so that would be that would be in C 1
and C 2 and C 3 and C 4
all the way up to M C and ok that's what
we're actually trying to do in fact it's
we're probably just joining now that
that's what I'm trying to do as a
strategy right that's an C 1 and C 2 and
C 3 all the way up up a 2 and C and okay
so you've got your first time yeah and
you're lost too okay so this is what we
are trying to evaluate now they actually
honestly they give you an enormous clue
because this part here on the end is the
required to solve the problem
it's they're putting you and saying hey
remember remember the reason why these
guys these guys are important is because
they appear in the expansion of this
okay so just to jog your memory right if
you think of just the classic example
you know X plus 1 X plus 1 squared X
plus 1 cubed and before we far enough
okay if you just think about your
Pascal's triangle this is just X plus 1
right so your coefficients are wonderful
no big deal when you expand this guy you
get x squared plus 2x plus 1 so your
coefficients are 1 to 1 you go down to
the next row help me out yeah there's
the 1 there's the 3 there's another 3
and then there's the one training on the
end if you're one more row down you're
gonna get 4 6 6 back to 4 because it's
symmetrical remember and we finish with
1
okay doesn't take much to go and do
that'll be 1 5 10 10 5 1 etc ok you
don't tend to see them very often unless
it's like with some multi-part question
this is multiple choice so that's why
they they kind of just leave it open
right now beanie you can see his pattern
for me okay when they give you something
like this it's like I don't know where
it's going to end that's one of the
strategies we used to make things harder
right it's introducing more algebra if I
just said three right just go up to
three that would be easy you don't need
to really apply that much thought you
just go up to three you add it all up
right these guys correspond to these
coefficients and out pops your number
okay so the fact this algebra is
algebraic is a bit hard okay now have a
look with me okay these coefficients
that are written in there I'm actually
just going to write the coefficients out
right this is the which row of Pascal's
triangle is this it's the it's been
funny right it's road number two if you
just can't even want you to fall but
it's actually it is the first row right
it's for dead equals one okay so what
are the actual coefficients that give me
one and what now by using this NCR
notation you might remember this one we
call a1 c1
I'm sorry one C naught and 1 c1 okay
it's a bit weird isn't it to say you're
choosing nothing but that's why these n
terms are always 1 because how many ways
are there to choose none of my Y
parameters and the answer is there's one
way to choose none of them no matter how
many white ball mark is you're holding
there's one way to choose none of them
it's well [ __ ] they're called whatever
C zero right so this number on the top
is which were you're wrong
okay so then when we go to the next
moment you're going to see zero to C 1
to C 2 right there are there's only one
way to choose 9 out of two there's only
one way to choose to map to right if
you're only introduced to and in how
many ways are there if you've got to
choose wrong to pick one of them answer
one way to X all right
hence 2 now you can see the pattern it's
forming right so you've got slide this
is the third row 3 6 0 3 c1 3 c 2 3 C 3
okay you're getting the idea now how
this relates to this is they want a song
now in a particular song okay so let's
try and follow this pattern that see
what's going on right when I add up
these guys that's just 1 plus 1 2 no big
deal okay
we're now these guys I'm adding 1 plus 2
plus 1 which is 4 and then when I add up
these guys I'm doing 1 plus 3 plus 3
plus 1 which is 8 so the pattern has
formed ok you see the pattern
okay now therefore you can rewrite these
numbers as su the 1 2 squared
too cute in other words it's 2 to the
end if if careful not there to get to
the end if I add up all of the items in
the world does that make sense
I've got to add them all up ok now look
carefully if the question read carefully
is the question asking me to add up all
the terms in the world and the answer is
it's missing one look I read it out here
right and see 1 2 3 4 all the way up to
here
I'm missing zero and ringing that time
okay now of course the first time the
first time in each row is always one
right so therefore I'm not to the M we
call this a distractor yes but I'm
actually not kidding multiple choice
question designs a big deal and they're
called distractors because you think
about this right so you can see he's the
Intel right if this was the actual
answer and all the rest of the answer to
like you know blacks 1 and 256 is 19
okay then you know they obviously if you
take a different approach to doing this
you can possibly end up with 0 so this
is the better distractor as you can see
okay it's even put up the top of the
question to troll you even further okay
this is really what they're doing is
every time if we wipe all these guys off
you're always one short you won't have
to for it you'll have 1 3 so yeah also
every single time that you take the
first time the first times always 1
correct before you take one off that's
exactly right yeah one see not true seen
or three seen or anything C naught it's
a little bit like oh these are always
equal to 1 in much the same way that you
know these are always equal to 1
that's you know right so it's that
identity right can I be honest with you
I didn't know like when you yeah I
looked at this and I knew it was one of
these answers but I did it nerd straight
away I had to think a little bit I had
to go through this process in my head
now admittedly I can do that faster than
you can because I've been doing it for
long time but it's still the same idea
right
I actually honestly would think that
going through that process is better
than just memorizing this because if you
memorize this is just as much of an
possibility to thing the quest
they give you that and then you're like
wait which one is it if you understand
then you'll get the right one evaluate
the sum of all the terms that look like
this but I don't just want one of them
I want the the one where K equals 1 and
the 1 where K equals 2 and the 1 where K
equals 3 all the way until it's N and
then stop it
that's what Sigma notation means